Google cloud next 2017 hosted a
profusion of talks detailing the future
of cloud if you didn't get a chance to
catch the session
Google's identity as a service for GC
P&G suite then stay tuned because here's
the recap if you operate in a dual world
of on-premise and cloud you can use
identity as a service to extend your
on-premise identity process to your
cloud based applications Google's a
newly announced identity as a service
offering google cloud identity extends
the cloud identity solution used by G
suite customers to all Google's cloud
based products you don't have to be a G
suite customer to use cloud identity and
cloud identity makes managing your non
Google cloud-based application simple
with SSO and central provisioning for
administration ease cloud identity makes
identity management across your
organization consistent secure and
seamless to do so it offers a
comprehensive cloud directory that
stores your users groups devices and
applications they can access which syncs
with your on-premise directory it also
offers comprehensive access management
now your users work with a variety of
applications both local and cloud-based
from a variety of organizations which
means they're more likely to reuse
passwords and remember different ones
for each app so you can use cloud
identity as a way to keep things secure
without adding friction finally you can
use cloud identity to set the right
level of authorization and access
control for example you can require that
access to your payroll app requires use
of two-factor authentication
every time with short session token
durations both static conditions and
runtime dynamic conditions are supported
of course everything needs to be driven
by open standards so there is never an
issue with vendor lock-in cloud identity
makes managing your other cloud-based
applications simple SSO is supported as
is provisioning them centrally for
administration ease and if you're an
existing GCP customer it's really simple
to onboard enterprise identity using
Google's ID as a service what makes it
Google a compelling cloud identity
provider is the robust and secure
infrastructure that backs the service
based on our experience running seven
services with a monthly active users
account of
a billion users we apply advanced
machine learning techniques to identify
threats and design and build custom
hardened systems from hardware to
networks to software this is the same
infrastructure that supports Google
businesses while we don't support legacy
protocols we do work with trusted
partners like octa and ping to enable an
end-to-end solution for our customers
that spans cloud and hybrid use cases
use Google's cloud identity and
Directory as your master source to get
the benefits of Google's infrastructure
and use a recommended partner to help
bridge between cloud and on-premise in
all cases keeping your trust is
paramount your data is always yours and
Google will never use your data for ads
cloud identity meets compliance and
regulatory needs including various
certifications and we publicly document
security best practices including
employee background checks independent
audit processes and more to see demos on
how to onboard identities to GCP using
ID as a service and how Netflix has used
Google identity help power their
business check out the full session
video on YouTube and if you want more
recaps on great next content make sure
to check out the rest of our playlist
and don't forget the next world tour
coming soon to a city near you
[Music]